[Music]
[Applause]
he is nick wright our good buddy from
first things first on fox sports co-host
of uh that show on fox sports one he's
got his top 50 players of the last 50
years and i mentioned as the tease
telling you that nick was going to join
us that michael jordan is third on the
list
so one and two have yet to be revealed
but it's either lebron kareem or kareem
lebron so explain your rationale here
nick with your top 50 players
okay mike listen
i want to be i don't want to do a lebron
jordan thing because we've done that
before you know it's been a topic on the
tv show a couple times i more want to
talk about kareem
and the idea that kareem deserves to be
in this conversation
if in any if we were to say okay
take the guys who are candidates for the
greatest of all time
in any sport it's like hey one guy
has
as many champion nobody has more
championships than him of the goat
candidates he has scored the most points
or goals or runs whatever the sport is
of all the candidates effective everyone
in history and has the most legal vps of
everyone in history it would not be
controversial to say he should be in the
discussion so if it's a three-person
discussion someone who might be the
greatest ever is going to be in third
place that is just the definition of it
and so people got mad that i put jordan
there
i
jordan's pinnacle his peak
one could argue was higher than anybody
else's however the second place on that
list might be shaquille o'neal so why is
shaquille o'neal not in the top five top
six top seven he didn't do it long
enough kareem has more
seasons where he was a top five mvp
vote getter then michael jordan has
seasons
he has 15 times the guy was top five mvp
kareem so everyone says oh nick
you know you take shots at jordan don't
you know when jordan was 38 years old
comes back to the league and averages 22
a game for the wizards
kareem at 38 years old won mvp of the
nba finals could jordan at 40 years old
averaged 20 points per game creamet 40
years old averaged 22 points per game in
the nba finals
and so i just think his overall nba life
and we're not i'm not even including you
know
if we want to go pre-nba
michael jordan was a very good college
player good enough that you know people
said i'd rather have sam bowie kareem
abdul-jabbar went 88 and two and in high
school kareem abdul-jabbar went 79-2 and
i'm told michael jordan got cut from his
team i'm sure it was a very good team he
got cut from but green wasn't getting
cut i just think kareem has the better
basketball life than michael jordan if
you're starting your team
yeah your nba team
yeah and you can have the first pick
you can have kareem you can have mike
lebron
yeah
is it for one year or do i get them
they're i mean they're correct they get
their rookie season their career
jordan's clearly third okay clearly
third you would go
for if you get a guy for his whole
career and you don't know who the coach
is going to be you don't know who his
teammates are going to be
you know
that lebron
no matter coach independent can get a
team to the nba finals you know that so
and you know lebron can work with anyone
so i'd go lebron one kareem two jordan
three now if you're saying
i'm starting a team but the league only
lasts one season and i get a guy at his
pinnacle
i think shaq might be one no jordan
might be two
like if you're as far as one guy at his
absolute apex i i think shaq maybe had
the highest
but he just didn't stay there long
also when you factor in that the general
public didn't see the milwaukee years
with karim
and and he was i mean then he like he
missed out on the tv era and then we got
to the tv era and then it became more
about magic than it did kareem so i
think people missed there are a few
players you have on the list that people
missed because they weren't in the tv
era dr j rick berry yeah there there's
there's a few players that missed out on
that and that might factor in because we
saw everything with jordan
and i'll tell you where i think kareem
is a victim of his own longevity
he was in the tv era when he was a
different player and i think some people
are like ah goggles
slow sky hook you know magic steam as
opposed to this
so jordan and cream oddly enough both
the year before they were on the bucks
and the bulls respectively those teams
won 27 games both of them and oscar
wasn't their creams rookier jordan's
rookie year they went from 27 to 38 wins
kareem's rookie year they went from 27
to 56 wins
and he was the best player in the league
immediately didn't win league in vp
until year two but and in year two it
was the year jordan got hurt and they he
had the good the good the good playoff
run where they got swept by the celtics
but he scored the 63. cream went 12-2 in
the playoffs won the title only won 66
games it was it was up to that point
they had a 20 game winning streak it was
up at that point in time the greatest
single season anybody's ever had and
when you really go in so here's the
thing and i'm gonna tell on myself here
because six years ago i went on when one
of my first appearances on fs1 i did my
top 20 players ever and i had kareem
behind magic and folks have sent me that
and they're like nick
you know what what the hell like what
happened and the answer is i hadn't done
the research the answer is i hadn't you
know i did i spent two years on this
project because i thought i was going to
write a book for it and i had given
kareem
a totally short end of the stick because
i thought i was like compiling this i
didn't realize that
for 12 years to start his career he was
the best player in basketball every
single year
yeah i still go back to the milwaukee
days and also
you know when you think kareem you do
think skyhook but you also think uh he
didn't play in that game seven against
the 76ers when magic played center and
had one of the great game sevens of all
time so i think there are things that
stand out with kareem's career that
aren't fair to him but they stand out
because
that's what people remember oh all-time
leading scorer great sky hook
unstoppable wore the goggles uh and then
that magic thing in 1980 and i don't i'm
not trying to be pedantic here this
game's six yeah
and they won him six it was but it and
listen magic win 42 15 and seven it's
one of the greatest games ever he was a
rookie it's why magic's one of the
greatest players ever
kareem not winning that finals mvp is a
crime cream averaged 36 points a game in
that series 36 points a game
annihilating the sixers and
if if they had lost that game six cream
would have been back for game seven they
would have won like i
there are in my opinion 1974 when they
got to the finals and lost it was
outrageous that he didn't win finals mvp
in that loss but and at that point in
time they did give it you know they've
just given it to jerry weston a loss
five years prior so it wouldn't have
been crazy to give it to kareem there i
just i do now here is and i want your
take on this sincerely
the one
argument against kareem's domination in
the 70s is
how much do you give anyone credit when
a good portion of the best players were
in a different league that's a fair art
like that that the aba was a legitimate
rival league had a lot of great players
and that to me is a fair counterpoint i
still think kareem would have kicked
everybody's ass even if they were all
collected but that like when you were
watching in the 70s and i'm not trying
to be a smart aleck here like did you
feel like the best team in the nba was
the best team in basketball or some
years did you feel like the best team in
the aba was the best team in basketball
uh having
having seen the kentucky colonels play
in person against dr j
you knew that there was a lot of talent
there and therefore you couldn't
discount it you couldn't say well the
nba has the best players
the aba had a lot of talent may not have
had one defining team spirits of st
louis had a lot of talent but they
weren't a great team
uh
you know utah stars had a a really good
team
so you you did have that but i didn't
factor that in i just always thought
that kareem was the best player i didn't
go
and a lot of your guys in the aba your
good players were forwards you know if
it was george mcginnis or dr j so you
weren't it wasn't like he was missing
out on playing against zelmo beatty and
you know a big man he was going against
big men because you did have nate
thurman wilt was a defensive guy then uh
walt bellamy like there were there were
good big men bob lanier there were good
big men back then that he was facing so
i i didn't factor that in as much as you
probably did
no i just i i think that kareem's lack
of self-promotion hurts him i think
kareem
uh be listen let's be honest here the
the
it is somewhat controversial to be an
outspoken
black activist in 2022.
let alone outspoken black activists
turned muslim
in the early 1970s i think that colored
no no pun intended some of the coverage
of him he also from what i understand
was not the easiest guy to deal with in
the media i think that and so then magic
comes around
and is this million-dollar smile and
effervescent and i think it was just
easy
to transfer
a lot of magic was not clearly the best
player on that lakers team until
hands down by 1986 some would argue by
1984 yeah but it was
the
it at one point in time they had the
best player in basketball kareem
and like the fourth best player in
basketball magic which is why they were
so dynamic and i just think i think
kareem's story's never been fairly told
that's it he's nick wright first things
first co-host on fox sports one so
jordan's three uh you got kareem and
lebron or lebron kareem when you reveal
that um you got magic you got tim duncan
kobe larry bird hakeem shaq
and steph curry rounding out your top
ten
i know you love dr j he's 11. moses
malone kd greek freak isaiah thomas dirk
nowitzki carl malone charles barkley and
then uh dwyane wade
yeah oh i thought you're going to go one
further go one further so you can roast
me who's number 20. luca luca don
chicken
look okay can i can i explain it
can you list his accomplishments
yeah um second leading all-time scorer
in the nba plus points per game uh one
of only two guys along with michael
jordan to uh average more than 30 points
per game in his nba playoff career uh
three first team how many games has he
played how many games oh well i don't
have that off the top
but uh but i do know that the series he
has played where he's averaged 32 nine
and eight in his playoff career um two
of those series were against kawhi
leonard and paul george and the two the
two best wing defenders of massive i'm
told then next series he played in was
against the three-time defensive player
rudy gobert the next series he played in
was against the 64 win phoenix suns and
then next series he played in was
against the golden state warriors who
i'm told have the greatest defender ever
draymond green if you don't believe me
ask him so he's done all that he is
three-time first-team all-nba for the
record seth curry only has four he
didn't blast [ __ ] steph curry now steph
curry also has four rings i understand
that however there is precedent daniel
i've never called you daniel that's
reggie miller's bit uh and reggie miller
by the way didn't make the list don't
tell him uh if it was 75 people maybe um
however
uh listen reggie's the greatest 18 three
and three guy in league history
you have a problem that he's given too
much credit for what he did against the
knicks right yeah listen the guy hit the
guy hit a three-pointer with a sprained
ankle against the balls and he any and
he absolutely annihilated spike lee in
those commercials oh my god the 90s
basketball it was so great so okay but
on the luca thing in the 90s when the
original nba 50 person list came out
who was the controversial inclusion
after four years shaquille o'neal and
you know why they put him on there
because they were like this list is
going to look dumb in five years time if
he's not on there so i had to put luke
on there now that they didn't rank
theirs one through 50. i had to rank
mine well wait is this going to be 50
years from now that we're looking back
on this is that what you're saying that
this is once every 50 years that you're
doing this
oh well you know i mean are you asking
will this become canon will this become
you know an archivable thing princey
would you book nick wright in 50 years
from now got it so we can talk about it
but not 9 20. no he can't do 9 20. like
after 9 30 after 9 30.
[Laughter]
that was a good line yeah well francie
would always go hey how about nick
wright for 9 20. i said he's on tv till
9 30. and he would be very kind because
he said for the 17th time i can't do it
before i would have the greek freak if
if i'm using your logic with luca the
greek freak to me would be higher
so
when it's all said and done he'll have a
greater career than hakeem elijah on
who's one of my favorite people ever
he'll have a better career than larry
bird
he'll have a better career
not i don't think tim duncan
so i do i you think he'll be better than
tim well i think he's a he would be a
better player i don't know if he no i
decorate i think i think giannis is
i think that if chris middleton didn't
get hurt
the conversation we're having right now
is
wait
could giannis enter the
jordan lebron kareem pantheon like why
couldn't he he's got the mvps he would
have two titles he's like the evolution
so i think i think giannis is gonna
finish his career
as one of
the six greatest players ever okay i do
believe that i think he's gonna win a
bunch more titles i i think his
disposition is perfect
i ain't like lebron in his prime he
seems uninjurable i watched his knee go
sideways he missed a week i i thought he
i thought he had i thought he tore every
ligament he missed one week and then
averaged 35 a game in the finals is he's
brilliant on the defensive end
i so i think giannis and i think yeah i
mean i think luca will probably stay at
20. i don't think he's gonna get that
yeah i don't know if he's gonna win
championships i think statistically he
he will
be uh i mean he's already won
championships dan are you not familiar
with real madrid yeah you're not
familiar with his work in your league
are you not familiar with him taking
slovenia to the metal round of the
olympics incredible are you not familiar
yes i mean listen the guy can only do
what he can do and he's done that while
he's fat
think about when he gets in shape uh
nowitzki's up there he's high
yeah
sixth all-time leading scorer
yeah
i know you're not a dirt guy
um i love dirk
um
but
you like barkley more
well well i think barkley is a better
player
but better guest on the show better
guest on you know dirk class's last
appearance was really good you know he
talked about his rookie year when they
made fun of him and called him a lot of
names and
uh who else called wasn't there a story
with dirk when he when he joined us that
had come out somebody had said something
about him do you remember that
i remember there was another hook to
have him on but i love dirk you know
that's the
when you think of greg where do you come
down on and i don't know if we're out of
time
we're
just tell me quickly where do you come
down on barkley versus malone
carl not moses obviously
i got to give carl credit for what he
did how he did it for the length of time
that he did it
um
you know charles in philadelphia and
then running out of philadelphia got to
phoenix they should have won a title
against jordan
um
there's part of me that looks at charles
the way i do shaq that he could have
been
even you know so much greater uh even
though it's not fair to say that about
charles had six four or six five power
forward but i do look at him with that
talent and i think he could have been so
much better and i look at shaq the same
way
like he jack could have been the
greatest player yes he could have been
yes he could have been the greatest
player ever and it's a testament to him
that he didn't get everything out of it
he's still this great on the other hand
your buddy reggie miller got the most
out of his very limited athletic ability
the most
uh having watched see i watched all of
these guys
tiny archibald
uh who else what do you think of my mon
creep inclusion that was controversial
well i'm sure jerry west would like it
yeah that's true yeah oh i have so oh
gosh can i oh can i say one more thing
before i go all right
listen i'm all for new media i'm not a
gatekeeper all media is welcome yeah but
somebody needs to tell new media that
you know what is the oldest form of
media
saying
as it happened the era i played in is
the best and everyone else sucks like a
draymond coming all these guys being
like the previous eras were garbage it
is the same thing as the guys who are on
tv now who played in the 90s saying your
era is soft my era was the best like
that's not that's not breaking ground by
anyone doing it and that jared there's
only one person alive who's allowed to
talk trash to jerry west bill russell
because he kept kicking his ass
everybody else needs to recognize this
guy hit a 60-footer to force fine to
force overtime in a finals game and
average 30 points a game in his nine
finals appearances that guy's awesome
uh but he doesn't make your list
it's the last 50 years dan
so it's 50 best of the last 50. wilt's
not on there russell's not on there west
isn't on their oscars not on there it's
the last it's kareem's rookie year to
now
okay but when did west stop playing
well in the last 50 years but he didn't
accomplish it oh oh
okay you're okay
the oldest guy on the list is rick berry
the youngest guy who was too old for the
list is willis reed
you got mcadoo i love mcadoo uh not one
of the 50 greatest players he got walton
in there nobody's a bigger walton fan
bill's not a top 50 player of all time
didn't have longevity he had a
three-year window where he was awesome
uh and i'm talking just nba and i love
bill
maybe the
would have been the greatest big man of
all time the way he played but i gotta
go but you know we can argue about bill
walton uh don't have jokic on there
either oh do you well i know you'll
never have jokic on there not never i
made the list and then he won a second
mvp what do you want me to do i didn't
anticipate that happening trying the
ointment see you all right buddy take
care uh we'll come back a phone call is
coming up